terror group is it possible to have a
Ral I've asked you two questions should
Hass stay in power and are there a
terror group you're refusing to answer
either of them that is very telling talk
TV it's the only place where you get the
truth you've done a book on poetry
poetry and music for the many I love
pery we can agree on
that on TV on Radio and on your
smartphone this is talk
[Music]
TV tonight appears more going on sensor
net migration hits record levels in
Britain is it time for the government to
admit it can't solve the problem or
admit it's not a problem at all more
debate Israel and Hamas strike a deal
with the release of 50 hostages C
kidnapped by terrorists a 4-day PA in
the war starts tomorrow I'll talk live
to Douglas Murray in Israel a normal
thing Norman finlin is one of the most
controversial Jewish scholars in the
world his views on October the 7th have
enraged his critics thousands of viewers
have called for him to be interviewed on
the show tonight he joins me
[Music]
live live from the news building in
London this is Piers Morgan uncensored
good evening from London welcome to PE
Morgan un sensor 13 years ago David
Cameron AS prime minister promised f
today's figures show how far we have to
go to reach our goal they show that more
than ever this country needs a majority
conservative government which really
aims to get net migration into the tens
of thousands well Cam went on to
spectacularly lose the brexit referendum
in no small part because his opponent
has promised us that leaving the EU
would give Britain control of its
borders but it didn't and sucession of
tough-talking conservative leaders have
delivered precisely the opposite result
Theresa May repl Cameron after promising
to slash immigration with a quote
hostile environment Boris Johnson then
promised an Australia style point system
Richie sunak has made stopping the boats
one of the top priorities for his
government it's hard to remember a time
when so many powerful people were so
emphatically wrong about something that
matters so much to the public today's
immigration figures Show net migration
is at record levels 745,000 people last
year which was way way higher by 130 odd
th than we were originally told as a
share of the population more people are
coming to Britain now than at any time
in recorded history and it's mostly
legal the tens of thousands of people
crossing the channel in small boats is a
whole different issue but what both
things exposed is a government that's
lost control of the borders hasn't it
populist leaders both here and abroad
are filling the void that's created by
telling people they should be angry
about something and they're not doing
anything about it opinions like this are
increasingly common as a result
we've got that many people here and
we're looking after them but we're not
looking after our own people really
really desperate for homes and they
can't afford to live basically and we're
giving all our money to these the Asylum
Seekers well many of the people coming
to Britain legally are here for
perfectly good reasons they students
paying big fees and medical workers in
the NHS and God knows we need them
they're refugees from Ukraine the real
issue is leaders who scapegoat migrants
as a problem while clearly having no
idea how they're going to solve the
problem which come as no surprise that
angry voters are turning to right-wing
populists in
response well I'm joined Now by talk Tov
contributors Esther craer and paulone
Adrian and first from Tel Aviv the
author and Associate edit of The
Spectator Douglas Murray uh Douglas
let's start um with what's going on over
there with you and then we'll come to
this migration story uh a big day
tomorrow in this war a pause the release
of 13 hostages We Believe women and
children um what is the feeling about
this you know many people are saying
from a distance uh that this looks like
a sort of slow form of water torture for
these poor families drip drip drip of
people being let out no one knows who it
is until the last minute and so on Agony
for these
families yes it's a it's an agonizing
time in Israel
um everybody in Israel would like to see
the people who were kidnapped on the 7th
of October return to their families what
remains of their families in many cases
um and it's absolutely agonizing uh last
night I was with many of the families in
Tel Aviv as we were waiting to hear the
news of what was meant to be an exchange
a Handover of some of the kidnapped
people uh this morning that then didn't
uh happen we're now waiting for it to
happen tomorrow morning we don't know
for certain it'll happen we thought it
would happen today now it's meant to be
tomorrow um it's agonizing for the
families one mother this evening
discovered that her two children are not
on the list that has been given out uh
to some families telling them that their
loved ones are going to be in the
release tomorrow and of course there are
many families one I was speaking with
earlier their son's 21 he was at the
Rave and was abducted by Herz stolen
with three of his friends he's 21 uh
it's only people under the age of 18
that are being focused on at the moment
but many of the families feel you know
they want them all home and uh the
problem of course that Israel is now in
is a problem that Israelis know very
well which is the completely unfair
exchange of uh of the hostages the um
Israeli government is talking about
releasing three Palestinian prisoners
that is people who have for instance
been sent to prison in Israel for
carrying out terrorist offenses uh
releasing three of these people for
every one child uh that Hamas are going
to release and there's an added kick to
this uh Siran the head of Hamas in Gaza
who was the person who planned and led
the operation on the 7th of October that
killed 1400 Israelis and led to these
Israelis being kidnapped is a man who
was himself released in just such a
prisoner swap 10 years years ago that
was when Israel released more than a
thousand people from Israeli prisons
Palestinians from Israeli prisons and
returned them for a single soldier
gillad Shalit who Israel of course
wanted back uh so there's a horrible
kicker to all of this a horrible kicker
that we've seen this before these
exchanges the people being released by
Israel are people who stabbed people in
the streets carried out brutal terrorist
attacks they're being returned for
children
Douglas is there any doubt that when
this hostage release few days is over
that Israel will go back to attacking
Gaza to get at Hamas uh there are some
people who hope that perhaps if this go
successfully over the next few days that
it may lead to a more permanent
ceasefire but is there any appetite for
that do you think in the Netanyahu
government well it it really is a very
very serious conundrum this because
Hamas is carrying out what you accur
accurately describe as water torture of
the Israelis it can drip out small
numbers of the abducted
Israelis uh and it knows that for them
these are golden eggs uh they know how
much Israel uh cares about every citizen
who was stolen from their families they
know how much they care they know how
much they can drag out International uh
uh pressure on Israel to have a
ceasefire they know that they can keep
on promising releases and then let down
the families again and again uh the
problem that Israel has is that Benjamin
Netanyahu says that he wants to destroy
Hamas most israelies feel I think
understandably they cannot live with
Hamas uh and yet of course as long as
Hamas has some hostages has some people
who've been kidnapped it can try to stop
operations going on in the Gaza to
destroy hamz it's an incredibly ugly
equation but it's one that Hamas has
performed before as has Islamic Jihad
and other Terror groups in the Gaza uh
they are playing a game not just
regionally but
internationally and uh of course the
people who are suffering most are the
families who have their loved ones um in
what state we don't know a small number
once again promised to be returned
tomorrow again what state they'll be in
we do not know um but yes it's torture
for the families I'm going to be talking
to Norman finlin in in a few minutes uh
you've got strong opinions about him I
know you're going to stay and just
listen to that interview and then react
to that after which I appreciate just
before I go to the pack just very
quickly if you don't mind your reaction
to these migration figures in the UK
massively higher net migration last year
than we've been led to believe very high
again this year this all from a
conservative government that promised to
take back control of the board orders
and reduce net migration to tens of
thousands well obviously it's a
political failure uh a generational
political failure uh that's just sped up
in recent years that that it has
happened as you said under consecutive
leaders who promised that exactly this
wouldn't happen is a disaster for
Britain quite what a disaster it is I
think we can already start to see uh I
remember when Georgio Maloney was
described as his far out farri political
leader in Italy and she's now prime
minister I remember when G Builders was
described as this far out far-right
political figure who wasn't even allowed
into Britain in 2009 by a labor Home
Secretary and now he's the main party
leader in the Netherlands so if anyone
thinks that all of this just Glides by
endlessly without any political
consequence I'd just say raise your eyes
a little and look to the continent yeah
completely agree Douglas I'll talk to
you a little later thank you very much
yeah Paul I mean this is there's a hard
reality here this migrant problem is not
going away it's getting worse there are
more and more people now coming across
the continent trying to find somewhere
to go um and you're seeing a rise of
very right-wing populous leaders now
winning elections as voters say you know
what we need someone say something about
this which is why we always have to be
careful with the language that we use so
you started with the word the problem
there isn't a problem we actually
haven't you don't think increasing
population here a problem with the state
of our NHS experience of NHS recently
right with a family member and it was
horrific partly horrific and partly
great the horrific part was an A&E have
you been toe in an NHS Hospital Rec I
have three children it's like a war zone
right and you've got people who've just
had heart attacks being left on trolleys
in corridors for six seven hours I know
cuz I know who it was right and then you
get good treatment once you get through
that system but can we take Millions
more people in this country genuine
question
any objection to any individual can we
sustain that pressure on our already
creaking Public Services the reason why
there's two different questions there
it's are Creek in public services and
can we take more people the answer is we
need more people the second answer to
creaking Public Services is we need more
people because our public services are
creaking our government over the last 13
years has failed to protect our public
services our government can I it's
really important to point out it's
really important to point out because I
am also worried as Douglas Murray says
about the rise of the right and what is
happening is is that we're not being
told the truth about immigration we need
more people to come into this country
our net population is only rising at
200,000 on average over the last three
years that's it 200,000 that's twice the
population of Sol and what we are not
being told is why we arable to cope with
the fact that we've got no housing why
the fact that the NHS is crumbling why
the fact that we are going to food banks
why the fact that we our schools are
crumbling that is what we need to look
at the thing is over 50% of those people
those figures that you've just quoted of
the 750,000 they're dependents so
they're dependent of people coming in
Legally so workers that have come in so
we're talking women and children mainly
who rely on the NHS education all of
these things at the end of the day we
have to admit Britain has that seems to
be a big part of problem is not the
actual skilled workers that we need
which I think we totally can all agree
on that it's the number of people that
come with them yeah right family
dependence is actually a very large
number of people thing I understand your
point that we need these skilled workers
but at the end of the day they are not
coming without families and dependents
who rely on our public services but also
we have to have a conversation about
what Britain is willing to give up in
exchange for slowing this migration we
the reason why the conservatives haven't
tackled this issue is because big
business likes Mass migration it has a
downward effect on on wages so it keeps
wages minimally low we look at GDP
figures and we somehow resemble a
dynamic and growing and strong economy
when that's not the case we live in a
low wage low productivity economy and
that's the bigger issue at the end of
the day under the labor government of
the LA um over 13 years of a labor
government 3.5 million people were
allowed into this country and that was
scandalous you know labor is out of
control about what 1 million people in
just two years yes of of of Tory
leadership and and so that is scandalous
that's horrifying horri it's not
scandalist it's not horrifying it's what
is required unsustainable
and let me explain to you why if we do
not continue to open our door to healthy
young people who are going to be able to
work as an aging population ask our
government ask don't ask me an aging
that's true need you say who you say who
called it a problem David Cameron said
it' be down to tens of thousands
completely unrealistic that's why the
public believe there's a problem because
they hear the Prime Minister say that
and now they're seeing nearly a million
people come in last year which years not
tens of thousands which is where I
actually agree with Douglas Murray and
I've said many times before this focus
on the small boats was just a it was a
smoke screen well I think there are two
different issues I think illegal
immigration on the small boats has got
to be better controlled it clearly is
apart from anything else there an
insults of all those who are going
through the system legally but secondly
I you know I just don't think you can
have successive Prime Ministers saying
this is a big problem this net migration
we're going to get it under 100,000 get
it down to tens of thousands and then
you see figures like today where last
last year alone
750,000 but P immigrants have always
been blamed for the ills in society I'm
blam I'm not blaming IMR I'm saying are
what I'm saying is Well I I don't think
it is I don't think it is and I think it
will increase and because it needs to in
okay it's out of control by the yard
stick set by successive Prime Ministers
who said we have to get it under under
tens of thousands you say that
repeatedly and then you get these
numbers it looks like it's out of
control and my experience I got to say
of NH recently showed me we have big
problems with creaking Public Services
got to leave it there thank you both
very much indeed uncensored next SE a
rockstar the pro Palestinian movement
one of the most controversial depending
on your Viewpoint political thinkers in
the world so much that he was banned
from Israel Norman finl join me live
[Music]
next we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online onun your smart speaker as well
criminals to using XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten other no matter how
well trained most dog owners will tell
you a dog can turn do you know what I
love about talk today we do it all sunak
sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swearing off in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million 140
million so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin B
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking Li if you're walking towards me
and you're a vegan should have a great
big orange sticker over here saying
watch out vegan's about
the weirdest plank that we've had in
three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC mous man MC mous
man m m he should be easy enough to
catch this guy shouldn't he I mean he's
got a house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film sunak and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf of the reform UK
party kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solve this is
really unfair what what what's unfair if
it's on camera we not do an interviews
yes I'm going to do you're going to
resign yes cuz I cannot continue my work
when I say I am God I'm not joking did
you feel Elvis was controlling I've been
answering your question you answer mine
it's actually not my job to answer your
question
are you prepared to call h a terror
group is it possible to have a rational
I've asked you two questions should Hass
stay in power and are their terror group
you're refusing to answer either of them
that is very telling talk TV is the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love poetry we can agree
on
that
[Music]
welcome back to p s my next guest is one
of the most influential to many
controversial political scientists in
the world most recently he sred
controversy with his ferocious criticism
of Israel's attacks on Gaza many of you
have called for him to appear on this
show with thousands of comments like
this one I wonder if Pi's Mo going to be
brave enough to have Norman finlin on
his show well I'm pleased to say the
answer is yes because we believe been
being unsensored here and hearing from
all voices and so I'm joined Now by
Professor Norman finkl Professor thank
you very much indeed uh for joining me I
appreciate it and like I said a lot of
people wanted a lot of people wanted me
to interview you yourself tweeted that
the we we hadn't done it so here we are
I'm glad about it um I think you're an
influential voice and you've obviously
been very vocal about this since it all
kicked off I want to take you back uh if
if I may to the to October the 7th
because you're your first reaction to
What happened on October the 7th
incensed many people uh you uh posted on
substack uh a piece about what had
happened on the day and it included this
for the past 20 years of people of Gaza
half of whom are children have been
immured in a concentration camp today
they breach the Camp's walls if we honor
John Brown's armed resistance to slavery
if we honor the Jews who revolted in the
Warsaw Ghetto the moral consistency
commands that we honor the heroic
resistance in Gaza I for one will never
begrudge on the contrary it warms every
fiber of my soul the scenes of Gaza
smiling children as the Arrogant Jewish
supremacist oppressors have finally been
humbled and you ended by saying the
stars above in heaven are looking kindly
down Glory Glory Hallelujah The Souls of
Gaza go marching
on with the benefit of of a few weeks
now do you regret the tone of that
initial response to what happened
my initial response was to the initial
news stories you will recall I'm sure
that initially what we were informed was
that there was a break uh breakout from
Gaza concentration camp that
approximately 1,500 people had broken
out and that about 50 people that was
the initial number that was given
approximately 50 Israelis were killed
the number gradually grew went from 50 a
couple of days later it went to 100 and
I'm sure you'll remember the number
didn't reach 1,400 until about 10 days
later initially it was reasonable excuse
me it was reasonable to assume that
people had been killed in a firefight
which was not the case at least not
fully the case so my initial reaction
ction was to the initial news stories by
the third or fourth day I was clearly
compelled to rethink my initial
statements and try to make sense of what
was clearly a moral quander and at that
point I revised my not revised but I uh
considered my judgment on the basis of
the new information
that was available okay and my own s yes
goad that's what I I just want to look
I've done a timeline uh for my own
benefit uh based on what happened that
day we know the attacks began at 6:30 in
the morning uh we know that
118 a.m. Israel confirmed as you say 40
dead 700 injured at 11:35 Benjamin
Netanyahu said we are at War at 12:30
that day at lunchtime I tweeted
horrifying and appalling scenes from
Israel this murderous indiscriminate
Hamas terror attack on Israeli people is
shameful and indefensible by
417 Israel said 100 were dead at least
985 wounded civilian hostages have been
taken at 4:00 a little later than that
around the same time footage is released
of ATT attack reporting that 3,000 bombs
and Firearms have been fired off by
Hamas civilians have been killed and so
on uh and yet at 6 30 and then again at
at
916 you were retweeting your initial uh
substack uh and you then added at
916 uh that the you felt the hostage
situation was crocodile tears so I would
take issue uh with your uh statement
that you thought it was only after two
or three days anyone had a clue about
the scale of what had happened here it
was very obvious during that Saturday
about the mounting scale of of horror
and I just don't understand why someone
as scholarly as you as expert in this
region in this conflict as you are why
your response would be that for several
days one of glorifying in the uh in what
in what you called heroic resistance
whereas mine and I've always tried to be
fair-minded about this conflict and
reported it for CNN and tried to be fair
and accurate as of when I've seen it uh
that I at midday that day I'm talking
about a murderous indiscriminant terror
attack and horrifying and appalling
scenes I just don't I just don't believe
that you weren't aware with great
respect about the scale of what was
going
on okay Pierce let me Begin by saying I
want to have a civil
conversation and I'm going to do my
darnest to remain faithful to the facts
and faithful to truth I'll do my darness
not to exaggerate the first thing I have
to say is I don't tweet I've never been
on Twitter I have three young tech
people who I send statements to and then
they make the decision where to place it
on substack on Twitter and so forth okay
we just want to clear that up I made one
statement on the first day on the basis
of the information that was available to
me the information was 50 people people
had been killed now my memory is but I
won't claim my memory is infallible the
numbers didn't start to grow until the
next day that's not true as the numbers
okay it's just not true PE well
Professor with okay I'm not going it's
not true Pi Piers Piers yeah but you
have to listen to what I say but you
want me to you want me to believe you
and you say you weren't aware of the
scale of this for several days and I
find that just I'm incredulous you want
me to believe that okay Pier Pierce
Pierce I'm not going to force you to
believe it and I'm not going to even try
to impose my will I'm simply saying as a
factual matter speaking for myself I was
not aware that the numbers had been
beyond 50 when I made that statement I
will further State I will further state
that to my knowledge I could be mistaken
that I did not make another
statement until the numbers start to
grow and I admit I have said to you it
was a moral quander for me and I said in
many interviews that it was for me a
very burdened moment because I wasn't
entirely confident in my moral judgment
and it was at that point that I started
to look back at what the white
abolitionists had to say when Nat Turner
carried out a slave rebellion and many
whites
were uh hacked to death children were
beheaded and I wanted to see because I
was not confident of my moral judgment I
wanted to see what did the white
abolitionists those who fought against
slavery had to say and I looked at what
William Lloyd Garrison probably the most
famous of the white abolitionists and he
said horrible things happened during Nat
Turner's Rebellion but if you read his
statement he wouldn't condemn Nat Turner
or Nat Turner well let me ask you okay
so let me ask you oh let me ask you okay
I've heard you say this before that
analogy that's fine but let me ask you
given you now know the scale of what
happened given you know 1,00 people were
killed including 800 or so completely
innocent civilians we we know that
children were killed that grandmothers
were killed and their deaths face time
to their families we know that over 200
people were were kidnapped and taken
hostage given you know the full scale of
this attack I've asked a lot of guests
this these two questions and I'll be
curious about your answer one would you
categorize it as a terror attack and
secondly would you condemn Hamas for
what they
did my view is is follows number one as
far as the evidence shows now atrocities
occurred on October 7th the magnitude of
the atrocities and the types of
atrocities for example where children
beheaded where women raped that remains
so far as I can tell from the evidence
an open question however that there were
atrocities that occurred my answer is
yes number two that's a that's a factual
question then there the question was was
it a terror
attack yeah well atrocities it seems to
me denotes a terror attack
that's what atrocities are okay so
number two that's the factual question
and then there is the legal question as
a matter of law it seems
unquestionable that the people who
perpetrated these atrocities would be
prosecuted and convicted in a court of
law however I would say on the legal
question I should think that there would
be some mercy shown
because those who carried out the
atrocities were concentration camp
inmates number three which I think is
the one that concerns you the most is
the moral question and at a moral level
my view is my basic precept we may
disagree my basic precept is that
there're but for the grace of God go I
that is to say I'm very reluctant
to condemn people who are in a position
or in a condition such that where I in
that position or condition I'm not sure
what I would do now the 1500 young men
who burst the gates of Gaza they were
born into a concentration camp they
lived for two decades in a concentration
camp they had no past
they had no present they had no future
they had no jobs half of them according
to humanitarian organizations suffered
from what's called severe food
insecurity and then on top of that as
I'm sure you know Pierce because you
keep up with the news periodically
Israel goes into Gaza and it Ms the lawn
and you know what mows the lawn means
it means a Hightech massacre in Gaza in
20089 operation
castled
2012 operation pillar of
Defense
2014 operation protective Edge and then
each of these high tech massacres
visited on the people of
Gaza in some cases hundreds in some
cases thousands of Palestinians are
killed okay and let me ask you in fact
just in oper well let me ask you on that
point in light of I want to finish I
want to fin one question about that in
that period yes in that period And by
the way I I've been condemnatory of some
of the things you've just talked about
publicly I've tweeted my condemnation of
some of these things uh and I've I've
tried to shine a light on the plot of
the Palestinians for many many years and
I feel that the oppression uh of the
Palestinian people for many decades has
been absolutely outrageous so on that we
can completely agree um but when it
comes to what you're saying here it
seems to me what you're trying to paint
is a picture of some kind of moral
justification for what Hamas did and
that's where you lose me because I don't
see why there could be any anyone who
can see the scale of what Hamas did on
October 7th and not simply condemn it
out of hand you may also want to condemn
some of the response by Israel that's
completely normal I would say that there
are serious question marks about the
proportionality of what they've been
doing but if you can't start from a
basic Humanity position of saying what
happened on October the 7th was a a
disgusting terror attack worthy of
condemnation then for me I find it very
hard to then respect anyone's demand for
people to condemn Israel and their
response here's I'm really and I'm
trying to be candid with you number one
I appreciate your Humanity
I do I don't know you from Adam I'm not
a TV or a television or a social media
kind of person I'm a book person I'm
oldfashioned however I do recall that
when that famous moment when Susan Bole
appeared on Britain's God talent and I
remember the
camera turning to you focusing on you I
can see it in my mind's eye I saw your
eyes narrow and suddenly suddenly the
humanity in you came up here is this
obscure woman whose Talent had gone
unrecognized and if I can speak to that
same program for me the most poignant
moment the one I carry with me my enti
since that moment was when Simon Cowell
asked um Susan Bo well why haven't you
been discovered yet and she replied why
because I haven't been given a
chance and that's how I feel about the
people of Gaza that's how I feel about
those young men in Gaza you ask me why I
won't condemn them because those young
men were born into a concentration camp
they were born into among the most
dense populated places on on God's
Earth half of the population of gaza's
children 70% are refugees who were
expelled from Israel in
1948 and their
descendants 70% of those of gaza's Youth
have no jobs no future no nothing they
are Susan Bole times
10,000 never given a chance and as
things looked the night before October
7th when the question of Gaza was
disappearing from the public stage I
will admit to you peers I
myself had given up on Gaza in
2020 I decided it's
hopeless it's
pointless I only have a finite number of
years left in my life and it's time for
me to move on and I'll tell you that was
a
wrenching decision on my part because I
knew I was abandoning the people who for
years I had devoted my life to
chronicling every
detail of the horror that had been
inflicted on those people and I gave up
on them okay and that meant if I gave up
they had no future because I was the
last chronicler okay but what I would
say Gaza I have the only book profess
that's been written on this let me
respond what I respond I would respond
by saying that what people in Israel
would say and what Jewish people would
say particularly who live in Israel is
that they were facing a constant barrage
of rockets from Hamas Hamas won
political power in
20056 that they were given a huge amount
of money uh and could have done whatever
they wanted with that money but chose to
pursue a path of effectively terrorizing
uh the Israelis over that period and the
Israelis you're right they responded in
a they have a far superior military and
they responded in the way that they did
and this cycle has been going on in
repeat and repeat and repeat but where
you and I differ about this is that I
think what happened on October the 7th
was just uh on a different scale to
anything we've seen and the way it was
carried out and I just don't think
saying that people who have been
oppressed which they undoubtedly were
for many years that that justifies them
committing that act of Terror but let's
take a break let's come back after the
break and and discuss this
[Music]
more we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online onun your smart speaker as well
do you know what I love about to today
we do it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police a pro Palestine that is just
not right you swear an o in the police
to act without fear or favor
the co inquiry seems to have turned into
a sort of pantomim there's not really
any substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy there
needs to be one human per machine to
come and rectify beats and the clanks
and when it goes roll unexpected item in
bagging area I know are we only going to
be trusting sources like meta and Google
where is our unbiased news going to come
from at Gram was president of the
Cambridge Union which is the rubbish
version of being president of the Oxford
unit Kevin O Sullivan is the worst
presenter on talk TV sitting on his fat
ass talking for a livit if you're
walking towards me and you're a vegan
you have a great big orange sticker over
here saying watch out vegan about
Twitter you sons of can you please
reinstate my hand thank you this is a
major Summit President Biden decided
this was important after watching a Tom
Cruz
film kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solved when I say I
am God I'm not joking did you feel Elvis
was controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your question are
you prepared to call h a terror group is
it possible to have a
rational talk TV is the only place where
you get the
truth this is talk
TV
[Music]
welcome back I'm still with Professor
Norman felstein Professor just to round
off what we've just been discussing
given that you wrote that substi uh and
you you want me to believe and okay I'll
take your word for it you were
completely oblivious to the reality of
what had happened here on the scale of
it um but given you're not now oblivious
to that why have you not remove that
substack given the language is so
clearly offensive to people people and
you based it by your own words on a
false premise about what had
happened you know Pierce that's a very
good question and this morning when I
was talking to some friends from the
UK I was warned you would ask that
question I'll honestly tell you I never
fear the truth I don't I feel the truth
is a very powerful weapon on the side of
the oppressed I know never fear it now
I'm going to give you the answer again
you can or can't disagree with me or
believe me I was tempted to remove it I
was tempted to quote unquote protect
myself I didn't remove it because I
thought that's
intellectually
dishonest I wrote that statement it's
part of of the historical record it's
part of the documentary record and I
shouldn't do what Stalin used to do so
when he published photographs of the
bolik Revolution he would take trotsky's
picture out okay but the image so you w
delet so that was that's the image stuck
to me do you all right you I've got to
delet it but do do you do you regret
it
do I regret what do you regret the
contents of that substack given that you
now know what really
happened yes if it can be
misconstrued to mean that I wrote that
with full knowledge of what happened of
course I regret it okay however it
remains part of the record and as a
serious scholar I'm not a great scholar
I'm not in the ranks of the Great
British historians but I take
scholarship seriously I did not want to
denat to falsify to misrepresent the
documentary record but let me ask you
let me ask you let me ask you and I will
leave it there okay okay that's listen
that's your decision you are the son of
two people who survived the Holocaust
who were both in con concentration
camps uh you're a Jewish
man uh and you know how inury that
substack has proven to be with Jewish
people around the world who many of whom
have felt this is the nearest thing to
the Holocaust of World War I that
they've endured what your parents went
through being Revisited on them in these
kutes on October the 7th um what do you
feel about them I mean how would your
parents have felt about you literally on
the day that this happened talking about
heroic resistance talking about that you
will never begrudge the scenes uh that
you the stars in heaven are looking
kindly down Glory Glory The Souls of
Gaza go marching on how would your
parents have felt about that coming out
of concentration camp surviving the
Holocaust of World War
II well first of all anything I write I
have my parents looking at the screen
behind me over my shoulders in a
metaphorical sense I am very
conscious every moment of my existence
every moment of my existence goes back
to the martyrdom of my
family so it's not as if suddenly you're
posing a question to me that never
occurred to me quite the contrary
I do need even 30 years after their
death I
need the moral
validation that came from my parents
martyrdom and the extermination of their
family how would my parents have reacted
my guess is if on the first day they
heard that inmates in a concentration
camp burst in its Gates I think my
parents would be very
pleased at that
fact as the events became
clearer my guess but this is pure
speculation my guess is my parents would
go out with their
hearts would go out to those who burst
the gates of the concentration camp
and whose lives were destroyed now you
will say to me completely legitimately
you would say what what would your
parents feel about the Innocents who
were slaughtered in the atrocities on
that date so I'm going to give you as
close an answer as I could give I as I'm
able to I once asked my late mother I
said to her what was your
feeling when you heard that the German
cities were being Terror bombed during
World War II the carpet bombing of the
German cities targeting civilians what
was your feeling and my mother's
response to me was
quote our feeling was if we're going to
die we're going to take some of them
with us now that's not the most morally
elevated statement I agree
and do I wish my mother had and my
father had a heightened
sensitivity to German civilian life I
suppose I would wish it but I will tell
you pierce to the last day of my
parents' life it was
Unthinkable that they would have a kind
word to say about
Germans and it was
Unthinkable that I would ever quarrel
with them on that point okay I accepted
I accepted that given their life
experience they had the right to hate
the people who destroyed their lives and
the people Gaza have the right to hate
the people who destroyed their lives
Professor figlin uh thank you for the
answer and I don't mean to cut you off
we've got another guest waiting to
respond to what we've been discussing
I'd like to get you back on I feel like
we've had a a good conversation I don't
agree with you about some of it
obviously that's been clear but I
respect the tone that you've adopted for
the interview and I'd like to explore
more of this with you another
time I want to just say one last word
everybody warned me you wouldn't let me
speak that you would speak over me you
would stop me I want everybody to know
you are eminently fair you were decent
and you are that same human being whose
eyes narrowed as Susan Bole began to
perform okay you have that humanity and
I deeply respect it thank you Professor
I appreciate you coming on thank you
very much well on say next Douglas
Murray rejoins me live from Israel
respond to that interview with profess
no
[Music]
think
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online we on
your smart speaker as well criminals to
using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn do you know what I love
about sport today we do it all sunak
sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swearing off in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what do we
saying it's cost about 140 million £140
million so far so40 million so far
results nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on tour TV sitting on his fat ass
talking for a liit if you're walking
towards me and you're a veg she have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in 3 years hundreds and hundreds of mice
in a box which he walks into a branch of
McDonald MC mous man MC mous man MC he
should be easy enough to catch this guy
shouldn't he I mean he's got a house
full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
fil sunac and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf of the reform UK
party hi
off kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solve this is
really unfair what what what's unfair if
it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to do I'm
you're going to Res yes cuz I cannot
continue my work when I say I am God I'm
not joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've I've been answering
your question you answer mine it's
actually not my job to answer your
questions are you prepared to call h a
terror group is it possible to have a
rational can't can I've asked you two
questions should a mass stay in power
and are they a terror group you're
refusing to answer either of them that
is very telling talk TV it's the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love poetry we can agree
on
that
[Music]
we're back on on S that uh was Professor
Norman FY listened to all that was
Douglas Murray Douglas you're respons to
that
interview uh several things I've
followed the career of Norman finlin for
many years um he's notorious for having
destroyed his career by among other
things weaponizing
his parents being in the Holocaust to
use his career to attack Israel in
particular uh I think all societies
produce a type of sociopath and
psychopath and I do think the Norman
finlin is just such a person if I can
give just one example he repeatedly in
that interview referred to Gaza as a
concentration camp gazer is no such
thing as a concentration camp and Norman
finlin knows that very very well every
single Jew was removed from Gaza
forcibly 2005 by the Israeli government
in 2006 the people of Gaza had an
election and they elected Hamas Hamas
proceeded to kill fata and other
Palestinians who did not agree with
Hamas and if anyone is responsible for
making Gaza into a prison camp it is
Hamas that uses places like the shifa
hospital as torture chambers for
Palestinians now here's another Oddity
about it he kept saying concentration
camp about Gaza do you peers know
anybody who got out of a con
concentration camp in
1945 and proceeded to go next door and
behead and rape everyone they could find
I don't but only Norman finlin finds
these kinds of comparisons to make and
makes them willfully and by the way and
shame on him for this what we just heard
was Holocaust Denial in real time he
pretends we don't know what happened on
the 7th of October we do know we do know
and if he doesn't believe the reports he
reads and if he doesn't believe all of
the international media he should have
come with me this morning to the
Pathology Department here in Tel Aviv
where they are still trying to work out
who the bodies are that are arriving I
was standing this morning in Tel Aviv in
the Mory with the doctors who are trying
to work out the identities still of the
people killed that day there is so
little of some of them peers that they
can't even ex ract DNA from them there
is so little of them that sometimes it
turns out what was thought to be the
Char remains of one person is the
remains of two people people arrive in
bags peers they arrive in bags with
little bits of what is left of their
body and maybe a bit of a mobile phone
there was the skull of a what I said
that must be a child's skull and one of
the experts there in the Mory said
actually we don't know because the fire
in the house the the Hamas lit was so
intense in its heat it could have been a
young man's skull that was warped into a
smaller size by the heat so if Norman
finlin practicing his Holocaust
denialism in real time actually wants to
practice any of the academic Pursuit he
has spent his career not pursuing then I
would urge him to go like I did and see
the body bags in the Mory here and see
what hamz did that day it is disgusting
that Norman finle uses his late parents
to defame Israel to pretend that Israel
are the Nazis in this situation all
societies produce sick individuals but
very few people have been produced who
are quite as sick as Norman finlin would
you ever debate with
him I said to you I refuse and I refuse
for one straightforward reason is that I
know a very very few people I would I I
would say I don't debate with but Norman
finlin is one of them most people I know
in Academia stopped having anything to
do with him many decades ago when he
wrote his book The Holocaust industry in
2000 claiming that the Jews were using
the Holocaust to sort of make money from
and so on most people wanted to be
nowhere near such a feted individual I
don't think he's somebody you can debate
with because I do not want to debate
with a Holocaust denier in real time any
more than I would debate with a
holocaust denier who was denying the
last Holocaust
this was the biggest murder of Jew since
the Holocaust and shame on Norman finlin
for trying to pretend that that didn't
happen or happened differently in real
time it's disgusting Douglas as always
thank you very much indeed for your
powerful contribution tonight I greatly
appreciate
it that's it from me whatever you're up
to Keep It Uncensored good
[Music]
night
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online on
your smart speaker as well they have
made a statement condemning Hamas we
expect to see the crown revisit Harry's
anti-semitic Halloween costume criminals
to using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn you know what I love about
sport today we do it all sunak
gun I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the Israelis are very
conciliatory all they want is to be
recognized the timing of this hamus
attack comes because there was the
expectation there was going to be a deal
down to normalizing relations with Saudi
Arabia the Tories love a scrap you can
almost see this coming around the tracks
with sella bravman she's heading up one
side and richy soon at the other
reshuffles usually very dull this one
had booster Rockets attached to it
certainly the tone has shifted in terms
of what Rashi sunak has done the
question now is what he does next the
police a pro Palestine that is just not
right you swear an o in the police to
act without fear or favor the co inquiry
seems to have turned into a sort of
pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy talk TV
has spoken exclusively to a member of
the Blade Runners do you have a message
for sadique Khan we're not stopping
until you stop for the amount of time
it's taken the number of illegal
migrants currently sent by us to Rwanda
zil the amount of money it's cost we're
saying what are we saying it's cost
about 140 million 140 million so far
so40 million so far result nil
absolutely nil are we only going to be
trusting sources like meta and Google
where is our unbiased news going to come
from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking liit if you're walking towards
me and you're a vegan she have a great
big orange sticker over here saying
watch out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC mous man MC mous
man MC man he should be easy enough to
catch this guy shouldn't he I mean he's
got house full of
mice this is a major Summit president
bid decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz film